Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Be-Connect!
So, da bin ich wieder.
Mit Rennen war heute nicht so viel.
Ich habe heute Mittag so viel gefressen.
Eine Riesenportion Nudeln gefuttert.
Ich hatte ja von gestern noch Nudeln mit Pilzkram und veganem Hackfleisch.
habe ich so viel gefuttert, da bin ich eben in den Wald gelaufen
und wollte eine Runde
rennen, ey. Ich war so
voll, es war warm, ich musste aufs
Klo, das war nichts. Ich bin 17 Minuten gerannt
wieder heim.
Bock gehabt heute, ey.
Aber gut, dafür gestern 11,5 Kilometer.
Also, das ist auch mal okay.
Und soll ich mal sagen, ich habe eine
Five-Head-Idee.
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das ex-lieferte es vielleicht ist auch komplett 3 hat es kann sein
auch geil kommt compilation ist gequetscht also passt mal auf passt mal auf pfeiffer
pfeiffer idee also stellt euch mal vor stellt stellt euch mal vor ihr habt einen linux binary
Einmal für Alpine oder LibC-basierte Bineries und einmal GlibC-basierte Bineries.
Stellt euch vor, ihr habt diese zwei Bineries, das heißt damit unterstützt ihr Alpine und mit dem anderen unterstützt ihr quasi alles andere.
Das sollte 99,9% aller Linux-Distributionen abdecken.
So, und jetzt ist die Preisfrage, jetzt habe ich mir vorhin überlegt, kann man nicht einen Rapper bauen, der beide Binaries Embedded, nur mal so theoretisch, keine Ahnung wie, ja, der beide Binaries Embedded und dann checkt,
ob er auf
ne Musel-Lip C
Distribution läuft oder auf ne
G-Lip C Distribution läuft
und dann das passende Binary
Exekten aus dem Speicher raus.
Wisst ihr was ich meine?
Ist das 5 Head oder ist das
3 Head?
Ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher.
Vielleicht muss ich warten, bis der Stream richtig
angelaufen ist und mehr Leute da sind.
Ist das 5 Head oder ist das 3 Head?
Und noch viel besser, ich habe sogar ein Tool gefunden.
3,5 Head.
3,5.
Oh, wird das das neue 6,7?
Weil 6,7 ist ja schon komplett out.
Hast du da nicht doppelt...
Jetzt wird ja nur eins von beiden gestartet.
Mit Go, genau.
Also, pass mal auf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das heute bauen will.
Nur von der Idee her.
Ich hab hier...
Ich habe hier ein Package gefunden für Go.
Hier, exec, cve, exec, v, it, was auch immer.
Und die haben genau hier so ein Exempel drin.
Guck mal.
Embed an executable in a Go-Binary and run from memory.
Ach so, doppelte Storage.
Ja, das habe ich.
Doppelte Storage habe ich auch.
Wen juckt Storage heutzutage?
Guck, und er macht genau sowas.
der erstellt
der executed
hier
der executed ein
Embedded Binary
und er baut halt eine Go-Anwendung
weil die überall läuft
ist das
5-Head oder ist das 3-Head? Ich bin mir da nicht
ganz sicher. Ganz ehrlich, eigentlich
würde ich sagen, scheiß auf
Alpine. Niemand braucht Alpine
für irgendwelche CLI-Tools
aber ich würde es einfach mal interessieren, ob sowas möglich ist
weil ich habe
Offstream vorhin schon
das Build-Skript etwas
erweitert, dass der die App
mit Muselib C und mit
Gilib C baut.
Das Ding ist nur,
das hier ist anscheinend ein known bug, dass das
nicht richtig
funktioniert. Das heißt, das muss man mit Alpine
machen und mit
ähm
mit Many, mit dem Many
linux linux image geht das anscheinend nicht also müssen wir uns überlegen und
wir müssen unbedingt überlegen wie wir diesen bildstab gescheit gecached
bekommen das heißt ich lege den wahrscheinlich ins ich lager den
wahrscheinlich ins docker file aus
aber ich war noch bis das stream nicht angelaufen ist dann frage ich das ganze
nochmal, weil ich finde die
Idee auf der einen
Seite enorm pfeifert,
auf der
anderen Seite aber auch irgendwie ziemlich dumm.
Ich kann mich noch nicht
so richtig entscheiden.
Weil du hast dann, wie
der Chat schon richtig erkannt hat,
du hast ein doppelt so
großes Binary, das ist aber nicht schlimm.
Ich meine, ob du jetzt 17 MB oder 34
MB hast oder so, draufgeschissen.
Aber
du hast
99,9
aller
Linux-Distributionen
abgedeckt.
Also insofern
finde ich das eigentlich
ganz okay.
Nicht sicher.
So, wir müssen jetzt nochmal gucken,
bevor wir hier richtig loslegen,
müssen wir mal irgendwie
unser Docker-Krempel
optimieren.
Wir müssen das hier optimieren,
dass es ein bisschen gecached wird.
Muss ich mal schauen, wie das funktioniert.
Ich kommentiere diesen Kram
jetzt erstmal aus.
Und dann warten wir mal ein bisschen.
Und ansonsten
bauen wir heute an der Kommandozeilen-Anwendung
weiter. Wir gucken uns mal, wie man
Progress-Bars macht in der
Command-Line-Anwendung, wie man Tabellen malt,
wie man mit Typer ordentliche
Command-Line-Applications erstellt.
Vielleicht ja weiter mit diesen
Fast-API-Geschichten.
Alter, jetzt will es die Playlist
aber wissen.
Monk-KS.
Machen wir hier wieder
eine Standard-Playlist.
was haben wir hier relaxing nintendo musik
Düt Düt Düt Düt Düt Düt
gestern nicht dabei war hat nichts verpasst unsere anwendung ist irgendwie glaube ich 15
Zeilen lang oder so.
Hält sich enorm in Grenzen.
Was kann das CLI tun,
wenn es fertig ist?
Nix. Das ist zum
Üben.
Du warst die letzten zwei Streams. Du hast nicht wirklich was
verpasst. Du kannst dir das Ergebnis
jetzt anschauen. Also wir haben eine
Python-Command-Line-Anwendung erstellt, die
im Prinzip nur aus
Moment.
Highly complex
dem hier besteht.
Das ist alles.
Command-Line-Argument und startet einen Webserver.
Es ging...
Ja, ArcPath schmeißen wir heute auch raus.
Aber es ging vor allem darum, zu checken, dass man...
Guck mal hier, Max.
Das kann ich dir jetzt zeigen.
Es ging darum, ob man diese Anwendung in ein Self-Contained Binary bundeln kann.
Und das haben wir hingekriegt.
Das ganze Docker-Bild.
guck, und wenn ich das jetzt hier ausführe,
dann läuft das auf einem GDip C
basierten Linux und noch besser,
wenn man Ubuntu,
Ubuntu 12.04,
ach, so viel hast du mitgekriegt, okay.
Egal, ich zeig's nochmal allen anderen.
Wenn man's auf Ubuntu 12.04 ausführt,
also ur-ur-uralt Ubuntu,
sogar da läuft,
ach so, ja gut, das ist ein,
was?
Hä?
Äh, Chat, was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Gestern lief das noch unter Ubuntu 12.04.
Ah, LibSSL.
Oh, nee.
Hier, da dran liegt es jetzt.
Aber wie kann das sein?
Wie kann das sein, dass das
GLIB C
2.17 braucht
und wir das gegen dieses uralte
Zeug kompiliert haben? Warum?
Warum? Verstehe ich nicht.
Hm.
Max, kennst du auf Redis
die Post zur Heiligen Schraube?
Ne.
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Sagt mir überhaupt nichts.
Okay, der hat anscheinend Probleme.
Der hat anscheinend Probleme mit LibSSL.
Guck mal mal, wie neu das Ubuntu sein darf.
Läuft es auf 16.04?
Ne, das kenne ich nicht.
Okay, auf 1604 würde es zumindest schon mal laufen.
Ich meine, ey, das ist immerhin auch 10 Jahre alt.
Das ist auch okay, ja.
Also wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen langsam machen.
Ich bin geschafft irgendwie durch nichts machen.
jetkis
wir können mal gucken
dass wir unser docker build
ordentlich cachen
das wäre vielleicht noch ganz sinnvoll
das ging doch irgendwie
bei docker konnte man doch irgendwie sagen
mount
cache
das probieren wir gleich mal aus hast du sieben mal eine minute gemacht nee das war mir so warm
ich hab ich wollte einfach 42 minuten locker joggen machen aber ist heute ging es nicht ich
war übelst voll gefressen ich habe es total gemerkt im magen es war warm und nachdem ich
angefangen habe musste ich gleich aufs klo ganz ganz schlechte kombination da bin ich 17 minuten
bin ich gerannt und da habe ich mir gedacht,
ich gehe jetzt heim und gehe kacken.
Du hast jetzt drei Stunden
gepennt.
Hoffentlich kannst du eine Nacht dann auch
pennen.
Ich das jetzt gepennt habe,
dass du eine Nacht nicht schlafen kannst.
Der Herr ist richtig im Flow.
Näh, bin ich nicht.
Bin ziemlich kaputt, wegen nix.
Weiß gar nicht, ob so eine gute Idee war,
dass ich überhaupt angefangen hab zu streamen.
Aber mir war es so danach.
Zumindest wird das heute
Lo-Fi-Stream, ey.
Oh, ich muss unbedingt noch was trinken.
Immer wenn ich draußen rennen war,
habe ich den restlichen Tag übertrieben durst,
obwohl ich heute nur 17 Minuten, also wirklich
abgebrochen bin, mittendrin.
Da wird immer literweise gesoffen.
Und ich brauche das anscheinend auch,
weil ich muss dann überhaupt nicht aufs Klo.
Also es bleibt alles drin.
Drei Tage schrieben in Folge.
Ja, es ist in der Tat sehr selten, ne?
Sehr selten. Lass mal kurz gucken.
Docker run cache.
Docker build cache.
Wie funktioniert der Krempel nochmal?
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Cache from, das meine ich.
Was ist das für eine Webseite, Alter?
Fish Wars.
Genau, hier.
Docker build cache from what?
Das meine ich nicht.
Das meine ich gar nicht.
Man konnte doch innerhalb von einem Docker-File
so Cache-Directories mauen.
Das hier doch.
Ne.
Hä?
Das ging doch.
Docker.
Run.
Das war genau, dass das ging.
War hier der da?
Ja, das meine ich.
Das meine ich.
Dass man hier sagen kann, Run.
Und dann Mount, Type, Cache.
Das muss ich auch mal kurz gucken, wie das bei Docker gewesen ist.
To use cache mounts in a build, you can use minus minus flaunt, äh, minus minus flaunt, Alter.
Minus minus mount flag with the run instruction.
Genau das suche ich.
Das, das suche ich.
Genau.
So, weil da kann man jetzt sagen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig checke,
Ja, genau, da kann ich jetzt sagen, wo, chat, jemand eine Ahnung, wo cc-cache seine Cache-Files speichert?
Wahrscheinlich im Heimatverzeichnis .cc-cache oder so.
Home.cc-cache.
Oder so was.
Oder .local-cache oder so.
da fragen wir doch mal die kai weiß das bestimmt dass die cash save als
punkt cash cc cash oder ok also wir okay das machen wir jetzt einfach mal
jetzt mal hier in das docker fall in das da und sagen jetzt hier vor diesen mist hier
machen bern cc cash machen docker bild docker bild minus minus file das so
Punkt
Ja, ist das richtige
Okay
Ja, cache dir
Root cc cache
Das brauchen wir
Da habe ich mir gedacht
Wir können das doch
Wir können das doch mounten.
Also das wir jetzt quasi sagen.
Wie funzt das jetzt?
Target.
Gut.
Also das wir dann sagen.
Run.
Target.
Root.
CC.
Cache.
Und jetzt mache ich das.
Was ich in meinem Bild.
Script mache.
Also dieses Gedöns hier.
Ich muss das hier mal kurz umbrechen.
Dieses Gedöns hier
mache ich jetzt einfach
in meinem
Docker-File.
Würde ich sagen.
Das müsste doch funktionieren.
Einfach hier UV
Standalone CCR.
dann schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert was mir ausgedacht habe xd hd aufpackt
funktioniert nicht option requires bild kit warum verwendet das kein bild kit
weil ich nicht installiert habe sehr schlau max low iq
Benutzt Docker nicht standardmäßig immer Buildkit?
Wenn man Docker Build macht?
The Legacy Doctor
Oder muss ich nach Build X suchen?
Ich dachte, Dokka macht das standardmäßig mittlerweile.
Ja, ja, jetzt macht er es ja auch.
Guck.
Das sieht man ja immer an der unterschiedlichen Ausgabe.
Jetzt muss er das Ding natürlich komplett neu
vom Scratch bauen.
Weil der alte Cache nicht für
Buildkit funktioniert. Na gut.
Dann sehen wir uns in 30 Sekunden.
Ja.
Richtig ASCII-Quarium-Enjoyer.
Das ist immer schön entspannend.
Wisst ihr, was ich
bisschen blöd finde?
Dass noch keiner ein Ascii-Aquarium
gebaut hat. So ein
Extended mit noch mehr Zeug.
Weil das Ascii-Aquarium selber
Das ist ja uralt.
Guck.
Das ist von 1998 oder sowas.
Das ist in Perl programmiert
übrigens.
15 Jahre.
Guck.
Was ist das?
Cat-Quarium in Rust?
So?
Ne.
Leider hat keiner bisher
sich das klassische
Askiquarium geschnappt.
Okay.
Man könnte mal
die KI drauf ansetzen.
Erweitere Askiquarium
um
Denkt ihr fünf tolle neue Features
aus für Askiquarium?
Oh, der bildet immer noch.
Okay, aber das scheint zu funktionieren.
Leute, jetzt
die Frage,
ob der Bildcache funktioniert.
Nein, wir können ja mal.
Okay, mein Rechner ist komplett ausgelastet durch das Compilen gerade.
Das ist zu viel für den.
Da kommt er gerade nicht drauf klar.
Ja.
Kennst du...
Askigvarium kenne ich.
Aha.
Was für neue Varianten.
Ich glaube, das ist halluziniert.
Ja, das habe ich zu pauschal formuliert.
Go Ocean.
Aha.
Jaja, Openlink passt schon.
Okay, mein Rechner ist voll am Abkacken.
8 8 kerne ausgelastet ist zu viel also die 16 kern hier sind ja fake da sind acht kerne
mit hyper threading und das sind halt dann 16 wenn er komplett könne komplett knicken
macht einfach macht einfach gar nichts okay das ist das das ist go ocean go ocean ist
go port of the classic es gibt im prof performance die frage ist kann das auch timmy den wahl
guck mal das kann sogar das kann sogar 120 fps wer wollte nicht schon immer
mal als ascii aquarium in 120 fps haben das ist enorm wichtig
Ich weiß halt nicht, hat er jetzt neue Sachen eingebaut?
Das ist bestimmt Vibe-Coded, ja?
Was wären deine
5 Top Features,
was man noch in das Original-ASCII-Aquarium einbauen sollte?
Okay, hier, da, er hat es geschafft
Er hat fertig, Compile Sort
Echtes Fischverhalten
Also Fisch-KI oder was?
Füttern, Interaktion, okay
Dynamisches Ökosystem, na
Zufällige Events
Ja, das wäre cool
Bauer mir viertens ein BAM
Jetzt war das war zu viel das war zu viel
ja und nein du sollst das in den code einbauen
das war keine idee das macht es hat es zu verwirrt jetzt
Das, das, ich glaube, das, das, ich glaube, ChatGPT, ich will eine komplette Version mit deinen Änderungen zum Copy-Pasten.
Ich Copy-Paste das dann, falls er das überhaupt kann.
Ja, und ich möchte es diesmal wirklich sauber machen.
Was zum Teufel macht das da?
Und warum ist das jetzt auf einmal in Python?
What?
Ich weiß, Chat-GPT tut sich mit sowas immer schwer
Aber das ist komplett derailed
Moment, das ist nicht Python, das ist Perl
Es ist Perl, aber er tut so, als wäre es Python
What?
Alter, Chat-GPT, was machst du da für einen Scheiß?
Hättschio keyboard schon kratzt
Ich glaube dass aber die idee finde ich geil vielleicht setze ich ja mal wirklich cloud
Code drauf an, ein Event-System
einzubauen. So, mal gucken,
mal gucken, ob unser Build-Cache
funktioniert. Ich schmeiß das hier mal raus,
dann baut er jetzt neu,
dann schauen wir mal, ob
der Cache cached.
Wir müssen aber noch hier ausschalten,
minus, minus,
progress oder sowas,
ähm,
disable build x
output,
äh,
irgendwas mit progress weiß nicht wie das funktioniert minus minus progress
oder so hier minus minus progress plane das suche ich dass man ordentlich was
sieht noch mal gucken ob das bilden jetzt schneller geht ist halt ein
bisschen doof wenn man das im docker file ausführen dann haben wir kein output mehr
keine keine progress anzeige das hat ein bisschen blöd wenn man das interaktiv im
docker run starten haben wir eine progress anzeige aber was mit dem docker
run starten kann man nicht gescheit cachen oder müssen cash directory
mountain oder sowas das wird natürlich auch funktionieren
Jetzt die Frage, benutzt er jetzt die gecacheten Sachen oder nicht?
Wow!
Sagt er denn, dass er CC-Cache benutzt?
ChatGIS
Geht nicht
Minus Minus Progress Playen während
Docker Build, hab ich doch gemacht
Ist auch hier, dann hat er aber
das, checkt das Ding nicht
Sagt er denn, dass er
CC Cache benutzt
Dann werden wir das gerade nochmal canceln hier.
Das da kommt weg.
jetzt machen wir das nochmal bild
jetzt gehen wir nochmal unser bild skript rein
so und jetzt mountain war mal hier was mountain war mal einfach nur zum testen
Okay, jetzt mounten wir mal hier pwd slash .cccache nach root .cccache.
Oder wo war das? Root?
Root .cccache.
Und gucken, ob danach dann was drinne liegt.
Bild.
Bam.
Schauen wir mal.
Hier.
.cccache.
Nö.
Das juckt das überhaupt nicht.
Oder muss ich warten, bis das
Compile-Stells anmacht?
Okay, weil ich will schon unser Docker-Bild
ein bisschen beschleunigen.
Subscribe!
Bist du der Chain-Lore?
Was so ein...
Nee, der Sinux ist es, nicht der Chain-Lore.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
PC cached das jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Macht das jetzt irgendwas?
Ich will das schon einmal wenigstens...
Ne, ich dachte, der schreibt was.
Ne.
Wo speichert der das denn?
ok abbrechen abbrechen wo speichert der der depp das
ok docker run unser image
bild speichert das hier vielleicht in dem ordner der kahn und das
probieren wir das mal von hand aus also jetzt erst einmal installieren wird cc
cash und gucken ja remove cc cash ob er jetzt mecker dass cc cash weg ist
Juckt ihr nicht, oder?
Oder muss man da irgendeinen
CC-Cache Python-Binding oder so installieren,
dass das funktioniert?
CC-Cache
When invoking with identical
letters you can take a long time
CC Cache
If it's located in system path
Das kann man auch setzen
Okay
Ist eigentlich nicht gedacht
Controlling cache locations
The storage for cache results
of all kind downloads
cache compilation results
is done in a platform
determined by app.ds package
Okay
Also sowas hier
To base directory
Okay
So jetzt müsste ja hier irgendwie was drin sein
CC Cache mäßig
Da hat er schon angefangen zu compilen
Ne das juckt den überhaupt nicht
Ach guck mal
Ah, ne, Moment, hier ist Cash
CC
Ach, hier ist dieser ganze Shit, oder was?
Aber da ist überhaupt nichts drin
Alter, der jebaitet mich
Warum jebaitet mich das so hart?
Warum geht das nicht?
Okay, Export
Zu
Camp
Da wissen wir wo es drin ist
Ach Temp
T-Mux
UV
Ich will dass das das cached
Sonst dauert das immer so lang
Gibt es das überhaupt dafür?
Für dieses uralte?
Ja
Okay, bam
Achso
Export
Jetzt muss ich es nochmal machen
wie ist dieses Ding?
Cache tier gleich
temp. Bam.
Kann das sein, dass der das nicht checkt,
wenn ich das mit uv ausführe?
Leute, wisst ihr, ob Sachen, die man mit
uv run ausführt,
Environment Variablen
quasi erben?
Gescheit?
Ah, guck mal hier, Module Cache.
Anscheinend, anscheinend.
1542,
ja.
Also der macht da anscheinend schon was.
Schauen wir mal.
Wir lassen es einfach mal durchcompilen und gucken, ob er dann was cached.
Ah, Moment, ich habe CC-Cache ja wieder.
Ich habe ja CC-Cache aninstallt gerade.
Alter, ich depp.
Ja, install.
PC-Cache.
Sehr schlau.
Was ist überhaupt UV?
UV ist ein Package-Manager
für Python-Gedöns.
Beziehungsweise, nee, eher so ein Projektmanagement-Tool
für Python.
Dann kannst du
Interpretors installieren
und
Packages installieren,
VNs managen.
So, speichert er jetzt hier was drin?
Ah, guck mal,
CC-Cache.
Ah,
excellent.
Excellent.
Erstmal komplett
durchdrehen.
das kommt das kompilieren wir jetzt einmal
naja offiziell ist es nicht aber das ist wohl gerade das verbreitetste dafür und
danach kompilieren wir noch mal und dann gucken wir mal ob es deutlich schneller
ist
Ich finde es ein bisschen doof, dass ich keinen Alpine habe, mit dem ich das auch kompilern kann.
Wir haben auch noch eine gute Idee, was wir in unsere Test-Command-Line-Anwendung einbauen können.
So irgendwie unterschiedliches Zeug ein bisschen zu üben.
also wie gesagt, wir werden mit
Typer oder wie das heißt
nachher die
Standard Library Arc
Parser gedünst
ablösen
vielleicht noch
also wir machen dann Kommandozeilenausgabe
mit Rich
paar Tabellen und
ein bisschen farbiger Text
und Progress Bars und so mal angucken wie das funktioniert
ja
Ja, das ist eines dieser Tools
Blazingly fast written in rust
Was so auf der aktuellen
Rust Hype Welle schwimmt
Wobei, wobei, wobei
Fernseher muss man sagen, UV selber ist jetzt ja auch schon
Nicht
So neu, ich denke mal
2-3 Jahre gibt es das jetzt auch schon, oder?
Was hat man eigentlich vorher da benutzt?
Bevor es UV gab
da haben die Leute so Poetry
hieß das glaube ich, was es da gab
und PyEnv
und solche Geschichten
wurde da glaube ich benutzt
wie groß ist denn jetzt hier eigentlich
so ein Compile
72 MB
na VEnv ist ja eingebaut in Python
glaube ich, ne? PyEnv war
für Interpreter installieren
und so Dinger
weit ist in in rust wirklich ich dachte weit ist ganz normal javascript gedöns
warum wird es bei der wahl um bitter cash immer weniger das hat gefälligst mal ordentlich cashen
und nicht
aufhören zu cachen.
Guck mal, der Cache wird immer kleiner.
So, mal gucken, wie viel schneller...
Ich hätte jetzt einen Time davor machen sollen.
Mal gucken, wie viel schneller der jetzt ist,
wenn es hier
schön gecached sort ist.
Also Pass 1 und 2
werden jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht so viel schneller sein.
Aber das ist auch okay.
Damit kann ich leben.
Veed.
Okay.
Der Cash ist...
Mit Cash ist es deutlich schneller, Leute.
Deutlich schneller.
Das ist einfach in 15 Sekunden durch,
anstatt dass es 5 Minuten bildet.
Okay, okay
Das
Okay, das ist gut
Das ist gut
Override, ja, ja, ja
Also heißt im Endeffekt
Wir machen jetzt hier Export
Das heißt wir machen jetzt hier
Das müssen wir jetzt da irgendwie einbauen
Ja, also wir gehen nach Build
Wir runnen das, aber vorher
machen wir noch einen export wobei wir können einfach so hier schreiben esch dir esch dir temp
und nehmen wir mal cash dir cash dir temp es machen wir so im cash und dann machen wir uns
hier
.cache
nach
tmp
slash cache. So, und wenn ich jetzt
alles richtig gemacht habe,
sollten wir
jetzt immer schnelle Bills bekommen.
Hoffe ich.
Ich.
Gucken wir mal.
Cache.
Modul, okay, der macht schon Dinger
Der macht schon mal Dinger, das ist nice
Okay, dann darf das jetzt noch einmal rödeln
Und danach haben wir immer ein schnelles Bild
Sofern sich jetzt nicht
Grundlegender was geändert hat
Im Source Code
Können wir hier auch zumachen
Okay, das scheint zu funktionieren
Das ist schon mal ganz praktisch
Was dann noch wichtig ist, dass wir in unsere
Git ignore.
Da muss auf jeden Fall
.cache rein.
Sonst
saut das unser Git voll.
Unser Shit.
Hat jemand von euch, weil ich hier gerade
Vite sehe,
es gab doch mal,
das habe ich vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich,
auf der Vite
Conference gesehen.
Es gab doch sowas wie
Vite Pro oder Vite Plus,
Vite Premium
mit Paid
Extension dafür.
Ist das immer noch
ein Ding?
Und wenn ja,
mal eine Frage an die Leute, die es benutzen,
ob sich das lohnt.
Also für mich persönlich wird sich das nicht lohnen.
Ich mach da zu wenig JavaScript-Gedöns.
Vite gehört jetzt Cloudflare, by the way.
Das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Na gut, Sveld gehört zu Vercel, glaube ich, mittlerweile.
Haben alle ein bisschen eingekauft.
Die haben das wegen Vietplus gekauft.
Was kostet denn Vietplus?
Vietplus Pricing, gucken wir doch mal.
Beat Plus, die Unified
Toolchain, was macht das überhaupt?
Ich habe nur damals eine Präsentation
drüber gesehen, ich habe noch nicht
gecheckt, was das überhaupt macht.
Oder kostet das gar nichts mehr?
Blazingly Fast Bills,
ja natürlich, was sonst?
Kann das sein, dass das gar nichts mehr kostet?
Dass das jetzt komplett
for free ist.
Ursprünglich war das mal angekündigt mit kostet was.
Okay, und was ist da jetzt dabei?
Was macht das?
Blazingly fast builds.
Okay, man kann sagen
Veed Build anstatt NPM Build.
Ah, verstehe ich das jetzt richtig?
Das Veed Plus,
das sind keine neuen Tools?
Es ist quasi ein Bundle
und ein gemeinsames Frontend für schon bestehende Tools.
Weil ich sehe ja auch hier, dass die Oxfmt und so Gedöns verwenden.
Ja, sieht so aus.
Ja, das sieht so aus.
Naja
Vielleicht ist es gar nicht so schlecht
Sich das mal anzugucken
Ah guck es funzt hier mit CC Cache und allem
Nice
Cache Wars
Ja das lohnt sich vielleicht wirklich mal anzugucken
Weil so ein gemeinsames Frontend
Für Tools die man eh verwendet
Ist doch nicht verkehrt.
Chat, Chat.
Ich bin immer noch voll
gefressen vor dem Mittag. Ich muss jetzt wieder was
fressen.
Ich hab grad Sandwichmaker
Toastbrot vorbeigebracht bekommen.
Ist Veed jetzt der Standard
Bundler?
Sowas wie
Parcel ist jetzt tot.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was zum Teufel schon wieder Parcel ist.
Also Webpack und Gedöns ist dead.
Du hast noch ein paar alte Projekte, die auf Webpack basieren.
Oder wie hieß das denn?
Webpack?
Nee, wie hieß Webpack, oder?
Okay, das gibt es anscheinend.
Okay, kein Schimmer, was das schon wieder ist.
Aber ganz ehrlich, bei JavaScript Tools blickst du auch wirklich nicht mehr durch.
Parcel vs. VEED
Parcel baut modern
Frontend-Tools, but they work differently
Parcel focuses on true, zero-config simplicity
Also ich würde bei VEED bleiben, weil sich das
irgendwo etabliert hat
So, jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit
Ist der nächste Build immer noch schnell?
Also Parcel habe ich noch.
Danke für den Follow.
Übrigens, wenn euch die Streams und der Content gefällt,
ich freue mich über jeden Follow.
Grüne Pfeile, die nach oben zeigen, sind super motivierend.
Wie auf YouTube.
Erinnert mich an die
Days Science Last
JavaScript Framework.
Okay, okay.
Unser Bild ist gecached.
Es ist viel schneller.
Es funktioniert jetzt viel besser.
Guck mal, wie schnell der jetzt gebildet hat.
Okay, okay.
Also wir haben das Problem gefixt.
Wenn wir jetzt noch ein funktionsfähiges Lip-Musel-Bild bekommen würden, wäre schon richtig nice.
Dann könnte ich meine Five-Head-Idee nämlich ausprobieren.
Okay, Chat.
Jetzt, wo viele Leute da sind.
Ich habe mal eine Frage an euch.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das wirklich HireQ-Fivehead-Idee ist oder einfach nur dumm.
Ich hole mal ein bisschen aus.
Also, wenn man Binarys unter Linux ausführt, da sind die in aller Regel gelinkt gegen die C-Library des jeweiligen Systems.
Hier seht ihr auch, also meine App ist gelinkt gegen GLibc.
Es gibt eigentlich zwei, es gibt eine große und eine bisschen nischigere Libc-Implementierung.
Das große und mit Abstand am verbreitetste ist GLibc.
Und dann gibt es noch Muselibc.
Also es gibt die zwei nennenswerten Distributionen, die Muselibc verwenden, sind Alpine
und Void Linux
glaube ich. So.
Jetzt ist es so,
wenn man Binarys baut
und wir gehen jetzt mal nicht von
Static Linking aus, sondern
wir linken
dynamisch,
dann muss man
zwei Binarys bauen.
Einmal ein Binary,
also wenn man
möglichst alle Linus-Distributionen
soweit abdecken will. Man muss
ein Binary bauen, was gelingt ist
gegen Moosle und man muss
ein Binary bauen, was gelingt ist gegen
Libc. Bei Glibc ist der Trick
noch, man muss es gegen eine möglichst alte
Libc-Version bauen, dass es auf
möglichst vielen Linux-Distributionen läuft.
Das ist jetzt aber mal so außen vor.
Am Ende hat man zwei Binaries.
Ich nenne sie mal
App-Glibc und App-Moosle.
Jetzt habe ich mir gedacht,
So
So low oder high IQ wie ich bin
Das kann man jetzt sehen wie man will
Also ich bin mir wie gesagt ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das eine schlaue Idee ist oder nicht
Könnte man nicht
Also guck mal
Dass man sich das besser vorstellen kann
Ich touche das jetzt einfach mal ja
Wir haben zwei Binaries
Eine gelingt
Gegen
GLibc und eine gelingt gegen
Libcmuse
jetzt ist es so wenn ich unter alpine das programm laufen lassen will muss ich die verwenden wenn ich
unter allen anderen linux das laufen lassen will muss ich die muss ich die app verwenden das ist
die gleiche app nur mit unterschiedlicher gegen unterschiedliche c libraries kompiliert und jetzt
hatte ich vor eine idee könnte man nicht ein rapper binary bauen statisch gelingt ja so dass
dass das selbst keine Abhängigkeiten hat,
was nichts anderes, also was beide, was beide,
Embedded, das heißt man hat dann ein 32 MB Binary,
das Binary ist selbst statisch gelinkt, hat das Problem nicht,
das Binary startet, guckt dann nach,
ob es auf einem System ist mit GLIB-C oder MUSE,
und startet dann das jeweilig passende Embedded Binary.
Dann hast du quasi ein fettes Binary und es wird je nach Distribution dann das gestartet für die jeweilige Plattform, was lauffähig ist.
So, dass das theoretisch geht, habe ich schon nachgeguckt, aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ist das eine dumme oder eine schlaue Idee?
Oder umgedreht, ist das eine schlaue oder eine dumme Idee?
Würde es halt ein bisschen einfacher machen, man könnte sein Binary einfach dann auf irgendein x-beliebiges Linux klatschen und es funktioniert.
Und um die Sache noch ein bisschen einfacher zu machen,
würde man dieses Wrapper-Binary, das würde man dann in Go programmieren,
zum Beispiel mit so einer Library hier.
Weil Go kannst du ja komplett statisch linken ohne Abhängigkeiten.
Und der macht hier ja auch sowas, guck.
Der lädt ein Embedded Binary und führt das dann aus.
So, Chat. Hat man verstanden, was ich meine?
und falls man das verstanden hat,
ist die Idee schlau oder ist die Idee dumm?
Oder ist sie vielleicht
dumm und zu zeitgleich
schlau?
Was ist da eure Meinung zu?
Und jetzt kommt mir bitte keiner
und sagt, einfach alles in Go programmieren.
Das kann man auch machen,
solange man keine Abhängigkeiten zu irgendwelchen
C-Libraries hat.
Aber das ist ja nicht der Punkt.
Oder habe ich euch verwirrt und ihr habt eigentlich gar keine Ahnung, was ich von euch will?
Das Binary ist dann halt unnötig groß, das stimmt.
Ich will nicht statisch kompilieren.
In dem Fall, ich will nicht statisch kompilieren.
Weil du dann selbst wiederum keine dynamischen Libraries laden kannst.
Ich, ich, ich...
Ja.
Ich meine, man könnte das
sogar zippen und dann entzippen
und sowas. Dann ist
wahrscheinlich das
das Binary
gar nicht so viel größer.
Okay.
Also ihr seid euch da genauso
unsicher wie ich, ob das 5 Head oder 3 Head ist.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz
Was haltet ihr denn davon, wenn wir sowas mal bauen?
Einfach um zu wissen, ob es funktioniert.
Es muss ja
nichts Sinnvolles rauskommen am Ende.
Aber bauen können wir das trotzdem mal.
Da muss ich nur noch mal ein Bild
hier hinbekommen, dass das auch
eine App-Musel überhaupt bilden kann.
Ja, einfach bauen finde ich immer gut.
So.
Ja, wie gesagt, großartiges Programm wird das nicht.
So, zumindest eine gute Sache ist,
ich habe unser Bild schon mal deutlich beschleunigt.
Von 5 Minuten Bild sind wir jetzt runter zu,
keine Ahnung, 15, 20 Sekunden Bild.
Ich esse nebenbei noch ein bisschen Honigmelone,
nicht wundern,
falls man manchmal ASMR-Eating-Sounds hört.
Guck, guck mal.
Es geht viel schneller jetzt das Bild
durch den Cache.
Flutscht richtig.
Wobei, Leute, das ist gar keine Honigmelone.
Die ist grün.
Aber süß.
Was ist das denn?
jemand high IQ Biologe von euch grüne Melone was ist das
eine grüne Melone ist keine eigene Pflanzen ja ach so schlau
Äh
Ne ne
Ja so
So was
Ist das, so was ist das
Melone Galia
Zuckermelone
Der Chat wieder einfach next level
Der wusste schon vorher
Bescheid.
Aber ich kann mir auch
nichts vormachen, oder?
So, jetzt müsste ich nur noch
Jetzt müsste ich nur noch
das andere Bild auf die Reihe bekommen.
Aber da bin ich zu dumm für.
Wir können es ja mal mit dem originalen Alpine Image ausprobieren.
Weil mit Many Linux funktioniert es nicht.
Und ich habe hier schon gesucht.
Es gibt einen.
Genau.
No longer works.
Habe ich nämlich vorhin gefunden.
No longer works in many Linux
Musen Linux.
Und da kam raus,
dass die keinen Bock haben,
das zu fixen.
Und man das eher auf einer eigenen
Alpine Distribution
bauen soll.
Also da müssten wir uns jetzt
einen Alpine Linux bauen.
Aber das machen wir heute nicht, weil ich bleibe bei dem, was ich ursprünglich gesagt habe.
Scheiße auf Alpine Linux.
Braucht man für CLI-Tools eh nicht.
Wer lässt sowas auf Alpine Linux laufen?
Alpine Linux ist für irgendwelche Containerisierungsdinger und selbst dafür finde ich es nicht gut.
also meine drei lieblings container base images sind einmal doch fast crash für
self content anwendungen die nichts anderes brauchen die gegen scratch image scratch
image ist im prinzip ein komplett leeres container image komplett leer kleiner geht
es nicht mehr da ist wirklich nur die anwendung drin das kannst du aber hauptsächlich mit go
programm machen weil go programme halt komplett self content sind und nur abhängig sind von dem
linux kölner so danach was ich auch noch gut finde ist ist rolle ist die disco ist distribution finde
ich auch noch nice wir sind auch sehr klein ja und dann kann man auch dem jahr slim nehmen wenn
noch ein bisschen mehr zeug braucht das ist aber dann noch mal eine ganze ecke größer also scratch
ist halt so groß wie die anwendung distroless er hat noch mal so 23 mb und debian scratch dem
jahr in slim er noch mal 50 mb aber das sind meine drei lieblings container base images
da würde ich sagen starten wir mal unsere entwicklung unsere idee
das ist halt so ein ding da bin ich auch immer da bin ich auch immer ein bisschen hin und her
gerissen auf der einen seite bin ich immer froh wenn es mal zumindest eine shell in dem
jeweiligen container image gibt dass man sich rein exekten kann um was nachzugucken bin ich
immer froh. Auf der anderen Seite, rein aus Security-Sicht, sollte ein Container, zumindest
für das Production Deployment, sollte ein Container nichts enthalten, außer das, was
er unbedingt braucht. Ich bin aber auch froh, wenn es Container mit einer Shell gibt. Es
gibt aber, zumindest wenn man Kubernetes benutzt, gibt es noch weitere Möglichkeiten. Man kann
einen Debug-Container starten
und sich
die Ressourcen von einem
anderen laufenden Container rein
mounten. Das heißt, man kann sich
einen Debug-Container starten mit allen möglichen Tools
und dann das andere analysieren, aber
einfacher ist es doch,
wenn man in dem Container-Image
zumindest mal eine Shell und ein paar Basic-Tools drin hat.
Aber der reinen
Lehre nach sollen Container-Images
nur das enthalten, was sie brauchen.
Und bei Go ist es, Go ist halt
komplett go-artet,
goated.
Weil
die Binarys sind einfach komplett unabhängig
und funktionieren immer.
Und du kannst sogar easy cross-compilen.
Du kannst sogar auf jedem aktuellen Linux
für ein aktuelles Windows cross-compilen.
Da sagst du nämlich einfach
go, go os windows
und schon hast du ein Windows Binary.
Also go ist,
was das angeht, für portable Sachen.
Das ist das Beste.
So, dann connecten wir uns mal mit unserer IDE, mit unserer IDI, wie die coolen Leute
das aussprechen.
Wenn ich im richtigen Verzeichnis, jo.
Wir wollen starten, PyCharm.
Let's a go.
Ja, und wer sich wundert, warum das jetzt so aussieht, ich entwickle nur noch in Containern.
Der Grund ist Supply Chain Angriffe.
laut go empfinde erfinder spricht man die environment variablen guss und gott aus
das kann er gerne sagen aber das muss ich noch lange nicht machen das klingt nämlich ziemlich
behämmert.
Ja, genauso
wie der Dude hier.
Genauso wie der Dude.
Wie man Jason ausspricht.
Ja, guckt's euch an.
Alter, ist mein Browser lahm.
wenn der im Hintergrund hier Dinger macht.
Ja.
Das ist der Jason-Erfinder.
Und er sagt, man spricht das Jorzon aus.
Niemand nennt es Jorzon.
Oder er Ragebaitet uns richtig.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Dich hat ein Kollege nach was gefragt?
Nach Jotzon?
Auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, da kann sich ja keiner so richtig drauf einigen, ob es jetzt GIF oder GIF ausgesprochen wird.
Ich persönlich bin ja Anhänger von GIF.
Aber es gibt auch die Leute, die alles besonders cool aussprechen und die sagen bestimmt GIF.
Haben wir hier Jif-Enjoyers im Chat?
Die lieber Jif anstatt Gif sagen.
Gleich Spann.
Ein Jif-Zap.
So, jetzt sind wir hier in meinem Container drin.
Gerade nochmal das Programm ausführen.
Gucken, ob das immer noch funktioniert.
UV App Run 8080.
Ne, funzt nicht.
Also, ich bin im falschen Verzeichnis.
Okay, bam, funzt noch.
So, dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Typer.
War die Empfehlung vom Chat gestern.
dass Typer
beste ist für Python
Command Line Anwendung.
Die haben das Emoji
Game aber auch durchgespielt, oder?
Bei denen hat jedes
Comet ein Emoji davor.
Tatsächlich.
Da musst du vor allem jetzt...
Oder KI schreibt das.
Ja, das Ding ist halt...
Wollte gerade sagen, da musst du dir nicht nur eine sinnvolle Comment-Message einfallen lassen,
sondern auch noch ein passendes Emoji raussuchen.
Oh, Amazon Prime Sellout.
Den mache ich viel zu selten.
Prime Subscription Sellout.
Ich mache eh viel zu wenig Sellout.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Ich bin auch nicht darauf angewiesen, hier mit irgendwie Kohle zu verdienen.
Ich bin so faul, dass ich noch nicht mal mein letztes Sponsoring, den Report hingeschickt habe bis jetzt.
damit ich wenigstens mein Geld kriege.
Verdienst du eigentlich
noch viel mit YouTube, Max?
Nee. Ich meine, ich habe seit zwei Jahren keine Videos mehr gemacht.
Die passiven Sachen
YouTube schwanken irgendwie zwischen
20 und 40 Euro oder sowas.
Altes Zeug, was noch
geguckt wird. Also, nee.
Verdiene ich nichts.
Wäre ja aber auch unfair,
ja, für Leute, die sich voll reinhängen
und sich Mühe geben,
und ich würde dann irgendwie passiv sonst wie noch wie viel verdienen.
Nee, so langlebig sind YouTube-Videos leider nicht, dass sie ein Leben lang geguckt werden.
Aber wie gesagt, ich werde nie komplett von YouTube verschwinden.
Ich werde garantiert wieder Videos machen.
So, dann gucken wir uns mal an, wie Typer funktioniert.
Also, Typer.
Build great CLIs, easy to code, based on Python Type Hints.
Damit müsste ich mich auch mal beschäftigen.
Type Hints sind, glaube ich, diese Geschichten hier, gell?
Hier, return none und sowas.
wie ist denn eigentlich
der Type-in-Support
in der Python Standard Library
ist das so ein Ding
was eher mehr
Third-Party ist und kaum einer benutzt
oder ist das
mittlerweile
komplett im Ökosystem drin
wisst ihr das
wir können ja mal unser
Mauszeiger über hier machen
Ja, guck mal
Print hat Type Annotations
Also das scheint schon in der Standard Library
Ja, dass die gut sind, glaube ich
Aber wie verbreitet die sind
Aber guck mal, die hier haben auch
Komplett Type Annotations und sowas
Also gehen wir jetzt einfach mal von aus
Das ist ziemlich verbreitet
ok also wie funktioniert
Typer
Example
Create a file main.py
printf hello
oh so einfach mal das nicht
also
Typer run main
müssen wir machen
wir machen jetzt nicht
App main sondern wir machen jetzt was
Typer run
App main.
Ja, richtig.
Install and import package
Typer.
Main does not return anything.
Ja, das ist auch okay.
Dass da nichts return wird.
So.
Nee, Moment, ich glaube, das ist sinnlos, was ich hier mache.
Wartet mal.
App Main, wir lassen das mal so.
Und hier im Main machen wir das jetzt, weil hier machen wir auch Argument Parsing und so Gedöns.
Also Typer, Run.
Okay, Import.
Hyper Run Main wollen wir ja nicht.
Hyper Run?
Achso.
Ah.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, Run.
Wind.
Kekke.
Kann man so machen.
auch okay. So, dieses ganze
Arc Pass gedönst, das sparen wir uns
jetzt mal.
Kommentieren wir mal kurz aus.
So, wie geht
das jetzt weiter? Typer Run.
Ach, und da ist je nachdem
Also
jetzt kann ich hier quasi sagen,
machen wir doch mal das Beispiel
Name Strill.
Das heißt,
das möchte jetzt eine
Option haben, die Name heißt, oder wie?
UV-App-Run?
No such things.
Okay, machen wir mal Help.
Okay, so sieht
das Help von Typer also aus.
Also, I will name.
Okay, also kann ich jetzt im Endeffekt sowas hier machen.
Blub. Okay, Funds.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Das ist eigentlich schon mal ganz nice.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen
an früher habe ich mal so einen für .NET
so einen Konsolen-App-Framework
verwendet. Das erinnert mich
ein bisschen da dran.
Das braucht man
mittlerweile nicht mehr, aber das war ähnlich hier.
Guck.
Run App und dann hier die Argumente
einfach als Parameter.
So, und wie macht man jetzt da
Subcommands und solche Geschichten?
Hier, App-Command.
Und dann sagt man...
App...
Ah...
Ah, ich verstehe.
Musst du es DLI nennen?
Ja, das ist mir schon klar.
So, dann machen wir das mal so.
und jetzt sagen wir okay
und jetzt
führen wir app aus
ok ok ne nicht app cli aus
und dann
können wir uns diese Sachen hier copy pasten
also
app command
das ist ja falsch es muss cli
cli command
sein ok dann machen
wir hier jetzt ein command hello
ne wir machen command kek w
Mit dem geben wir dann
kekw
in ASCII Zeichen aus.
Hier machen wir nochmal
serve
für
den Webserver.
So, name brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen jetzt hier
port
und Port ist ein Int.
Hat Type Hints.
Da muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Type Hints.
Gibt es da sowas wie
U-Short oder sowas?
Okay, man nimmt einfach Int.
Nutzen Sie Bibliotheken wie
Pydantic oder
Ähm, was genau?
Used for data validation and parsing.
Was bin ich sehend?
Okay, damit kann ich jetzt nicht
einen Typ definieren, der
Kann ich damit
nur von 0 bis
Ich weiß nicht, wie geht
so wir haben jetzt hier den port und da können wir jetzt unseren camp hier rein
kopieren wenn ich das richtig sehe also starting on port hat es ist auch viel
angenehmer als arg pass wir müssen das gar nicht als in karsten weil es ist ja
schon ein int ok so schauen wir das jetzt noch mal wenn wir jetzt hier die
version 10 die help message angucken da sehen wir auch finde ich hübsch finde
für meinen Geschmack
mit
ein paar hättest du die C-Types
und der würde dann
an welcher Stelle meckern?
Ich muss sagen, so schön
das ist, ich finde die Help-Ausgabe
fast schon ein Ticken zu fancy.
Wisst ihr das?
Die ist mir fast schon
ein bisschen zu
zu bunt und
aufdringlich.
Also ich mag ja so
klassische Sachen.
Sowas hier, ja.
Ups.
The fuck?
Aber das geht ja noch in Ordnung.
Also wir haben jetzt hier Commands, Keg, W und
Surf. Dann machen wir mal hier Surf. Dann geht der Web-Server
an, oder? Missing Argument.
Port.
Ach so muss man das dann machen.
Ich verstehe.
War der Standard Python
nicht Arbitrary Size?
Doch, ich glaube, das ist standardmäßig
quasi Big Int.
Du kannst, glaube ich, in Python
kannst du, glaube ich, machen
hier, blub, gleich
zu viel Face Rollt.
Und das geht.
Das ist nur beschränkt
durch deinen RAM.
Was auch heißt,
ich könnte jetzt angeben,
das ist meine Portnummer
und dann würde ich übelst abkacken.
Logischerweise, ja.
Mit einer ziemlich hässlichen Fehlermeldung, ehrlich gesagt.
Overflow-Error.
Port must be 0 bis 65.535.
Okay, wie kann man das jetzt schöner validaten,
sodass der eine ordentliche Fehlermeldung ausspuckt?
Kann ich jetzt, wie validated
man das jetzt, muss ich das jetzt selbst checken
muss ich jetzt quasi sagen
if port
ja keine Ahnung
äh, größer
0, and
port, ja genau, sowas hier
äh
and
Simplified Chained Comparison
Ah
Okay, das ist ganz nice
Okay
Okay, dann machen wir mal was anderes
Mal gucken, ob wir das auch stellen.
If port kleiner gleich 0 und größer gleich das da, dann wollen wir was haben?
Print f.
Ne, nicht print f. Print f.
Port. Aber Validation kann man
doch mit Typer sicherlich viel
schöner machen, oder?
Hä?
Was jetzt? Was habe ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht?
Oder. Moment.
Oder
Port.
Hä?
Chat?
Ach so, Moment, ich muss ja dann hier Exit machen, Return.
Ich gehe ja gar nicht raus.
Okay, ja, Funst, Funst.
Type Numbers.
Okay, da kann man anscheinend doch noch was machen.
Ja, weil das wäre ja auch blöd, wenn man das so machen muss von Hand.
You can define numeric validations with max, min values for int and float.
Sehr schön.
Excellent.
Also, da kann man jetzt sagen,
ID,
Typer, Argument,
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, den Unterschied zwischen Argument und Options.
Das checke ich jetzt nicht so ganz.
Achso, required und optional.
Aber wenn was optional ist, dann und default value gesetzt wird?
Achso, das ist optional
Da muss ein Default Value gesetzt sein, weil man es weglassen kann
Ah, ja gut
Also das heißt, ich mache jetzt sowas hier
Annotation
Und zwar, wohin muss das jetzt?
Wohin?
Import this name
Typing annotated
Okay
Also, mindestens
Keine Ahnung, 1
Max
Gleich
65.535
Leute, stimmt das?
Ist das richtig?
Ja
Okay, und Default-Wert ist
8 ist... 1, 2, 3, 4.
So, machen wir so.
So, was passiert jetzt?
Wenn das nicht validated werden kann?
Gott
unexpected extra
extra argument?
Ah, so.
Ja so, das ist schön
Das ist schön
Inverted value for port
Das ist schön, das gefällt mir jetzt
Das heißt, ich setze jetzt hier port
1, 2, 3, 4
Zack, Funst
Und wenn ich es weglasse, nimmt er standardmäßig default port
Was steht an?
Ich gucke mir gerade Typer an
Wir haben im Vorfeld schon unser Docker-File
Mal um einen ordentlichen Cache erweitert
dass es nicht immer drei Stunden bildet.
Finde ich eigentlich eine schöne Syntax hier.
Wie gesagt, erinnert mich ein bisschen
an dieses eine .NET Framework
für Kommandozeilen-Apps.
Und wisst ihr, an was
mich es auch ein bisschen erinnert? Mit diesen
Annotations.
Hier vorne.
Ein bisschen an Spring Boot.
mit dem Annotation-Stelz hier dran.
So ist glaube ich für euch besser lesbar.
Hat ein bisschen Springboot-Vibes.
Find ich.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt auch sowas hier machen,
wie keck weh.
Missing argument, lul.
Hello, lul.
Schick.
Schick, das gefällt mir, das hat was.
Und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob unser Bild schneller ist.
Ist das Max FPS? Was?
Wer? Ich? Ich bin wobblos.
Aber schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast, Mr. Lebensblume.
Richtige Hackerman-Emos.
Wie hast du den Stream gefunden?
Per Zufall oder über
einen Link auf YouTube oder
in den Stream-Empfehlungen?
Jetzt gucken wir mal,
wie schnell unser Bild ist.
Da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt.
Das Bild sollte jetzt
deutlich schneller sein
durch den Cache.
Aber wir haben jetzt auch Typer mit dabei.
Typer muss ja zum ersten Mal Compile so an.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt bedeutend schneller ist.
Schauen wir mal.
Bin mal gespannt.
Ja, das waren zwei Tage,
haben sie sich auf Twitter aufgeregt
und mussten demonstrieren, wie moralisch
überlegen sie sind. Aber jetzt
interessiert es keinen mehr.
Und da habe ich auch prinzipiell
gar nichts dagegen.
Nur dieses
ich bin, ich bin
viel, viel besserer Mensch, als ihr
auf Twitter geht mir immer auf den Sack.
Oh gut, jetzt muss der, jetzt muss der halt
nochmal komplett, jetzt muss der halt
komplett
Typer nochmal
neu kompilieren, ne?
Das könnte jetzt natürlich,
Aber für die schon bestehenden Files müsste er eigentlich deutlich schneller sein.
Battlefield 3.
Es ist so schade, weil du sagst Battlefield 3, ne?
Es ist so schade, dass, ähm, Dings hier, dass die so einen Memory Bug hatten.
Dass wenn es Unleashed so wenig Support hatte und auch irgendwie nicht so richtig abgehoben ist.
Das war nämlich besser.
Das war das beste Battlefield 3 im Endeffekt, was wir hatten.
Wenn es unleashed.
Da war der blaue Filter entfernt.
Und du hattest höhere Tickrate Surfer und sowas.
Oh, ich hab, du hast recht.
Ich hab wieder diesen dummen Night Mode Filter hier an.
Wir sollten das einfach ausschalten.
Wisst ihr das?
Wir sollten das ausschalten.
Configure Night Light.
Nicht wundern, dass mein Rechner so lahm ist bzw. der Linux-mini-PC so lahm ist.
Der ist komplett ausgelastet gerade. Alle Kerne, alle 16 Kerne, bzw. 8 plus 8 Kerne 100% ausgelastet.
Switch times, always off.
Zack.
Ja, es hat eigentlich keinen Sinn, dass das überhaupt eingestellt ist.
was will er mich hier eigentlich mit sagen anti bloat anti bloat ist immer
okay habe ich nichts dagegen klingt erstmal gut wenn du hast nicht bloat ist
geht es ob die ob die letzten paar files jetzt schneller kompilen weil die schon im cash sind
Oh, ist das laggy
Jaja, genau, Ballstrike
Wie groß ist denn jetzt mein Cashverzeichnis
134 MB, Alter, was bildet der da alles
Gut, gucken wir mal weiter
Also, jetzt haben wir einen Command für Webserver starten.
Das ist ja schon mal ganz nice.
Was ich jetzt noch einbauen will, ist...
Habige Konsolenausgabe.
Beziehungsweise Rich.
Einfach vorher.
Viel wichtiger, Leute.
GitHub.
Vmchamp.
das wichtigste kommandozeilen argument was jeder die was wirklich dringend
jede kommandozeilen app braucht jedes die app braucht
was ist das lahm
das ist jetzt einmalig das jetzt einmalig aber ja die go compile zeiten
sind viel viel besser dass er muss jetzt einmalig die neuen libraries kompilieren
so und zwar das wichtigste command wo ist es das keck w command das braucht das sollte jede
ernst gemeinte
Kommandozeilen-Anwendung haben.
Probieren wir hier gleich mal rein.
Wahr braucht man hier nicht.
Aber, ähm,
hier, Content, genau. Aber in Python
geht das ja auch mit diesen drei Anführungsstrichen
und so, ne?
Okay, so, jetzt haben wir
das Copy-Paste. Ich hoffe, das konnte man jetzt Copy-Pasten
überhaupt. Printf
Printf
Content
So, werden wir jetzt gleich checken, ob das funktioniert.
Meint ihr,
der checkt diese Escape-Symbole?
Oh fuck, meine ganze Linux-Kiste
ist übelst ausgelastet.
Der Editor funktioniert nicht mehr.
Chat?
Was sagt H-Top?
Ist mein...
Oh shit.
Ah.
Das ist am explodieren, Alter.
Das ist komplett am explodieren.
Oh seven, Leute.
Oh seven für den Mini-PC.
der ist am limit ja ich muss mir unbedingt noch ein ram riegel besorgen für den mini pc noch ein
16 gig riegel und dann dann habe ich 24 gig und dann ist wieder alles gut der hat acht der hat
aktuellen acht gig ram riegel drin der mini pc und darf man geht noch mal ein gig oder so weg
für die Grafikkarte.
Der hat so eine
Mobile AMD Radeon
670M oder sowas
in der Richtung.
Also jetzt nichts
Tolles oder so. Aber der ist so
hart am abkacken
gerade.
Ist er dann irgendwann nochmal fertig
kompilieren? Okay, 80%
Leute.
Aber glücklicherweise muss er das nur einmal
machen.
Nur einmal Compile sollen danach ist gecached
Da ich habe
Er muss jetzt halter neu kompilieren
Pregel, Pregel.
Jetzt nicht verrecken.
10 Sekunden vor Schluss.
Du wurdest nur einmal
geratiot und nicht so krass.
Was soll das bedeuten?
da bin ich zu boomer für was was bedeutet das gleich haben wir es wenn
der top kommentar mehr likes hat als der eigentliche post weil es kein dislike
gibt das so mich nicht die ganzen moralischen leute dann wieder
über nutzte zettel haben er ich glaube gleich fertig
die kiste sollte jetzt schon mal deutlich besser wieder jahres wieder
responsive also jetzt haben wir hier eingebaut ab keck bm missing gut und da
Da ist es. Es funzt.
Beste.
Das braucht jede Kommandozeilen-App.
Ohne geht nicht.
Unusable.
Unusable ohne.
Komplett unusable.
Und das Terminal muss auch so hoch eingestellt werden,
dass es reinpasst.
Oh, ist das gut.
Excellent. Jetzt bin ich zufrieden.
Typo in the world? Keck W.
Jet Brains.
Was ist denn mit euch los?
Oder ist Jet Brains so schlau und weiß, es muss Keck W heißen?
Groß. Nein, auch nicht.
Content.
Shadows name from outer scope.
Ah, App Content.
Text.
Okay.
Schon mal wichtiges, wichtiges Command am Start.
So, was kann man denn?
Ich muss mir jetzt mal den Guide weiter angucken.
Wie sieht es denn jetzt aus mit...
Oh, hier.
Commands haben wir schon.
Passt.
Ach so, geht dann jetzt...
Jetzt muss ich mal checken. Jetzt habe ich ja ein paar Sachen hier angepasst.
Wenn ich jetzt den Compile-Vorgang
nochmal starte, ist er dann
schneller, weil gecached
er müsste eigentlich.
Wenn nicht, drehe ich am Rad, ey.
Weil ich gucke mir garantiert nicht immer 5 Minuten kompilieren an, bei voll ausgelastetem Rechner.
Ich miete mir einfach eine Cloud-Kiste mit 64 Kernen.
Nur um ein Python-Skript zu kompilen.
Das ist bestimmt preis-leistungsmäßig voll gut.
GTA 6.
Ich...
Ich verstehe den Hype um GTA immer nicht.
Ich habe die ersten GTAs gespielt.
Und irgendwann hatte ich einfach keinen Bock mehr.
Das ist nicht mein Game.
GTA 5 habe ich mir auch gekauft.
Angefangen hat mir nichts gegeben irgendwie.
Okay, aber es ist deutlich schneller im Compile.
Hat mir nichts gegeben.
Also ich weiß, GTA 6 wird einen riesen Hype haben.
Einfach nur weil es GTA ist.
Aber bisher haben die GTA-Spieler einfach irgendwie nichts gegeben, nichts zugesagt.
Ich bin kein großer GTA-Fan.
Im Gegenzug würde ich komplett ausrasten, wenn es endlich Half-Life 3 gibt.
Chat, ich glaube in der heutigen Zeit ist der Hype um GTA 6 mit Sicherheit höher als der Hype um Half-Life 3.
Weil Half-Life 2 kam wann raus? 2005?
Das ist 20 Jahre her.
Aber wisst ihr, was krass ist?
Wisst ihr, was echt krass ist?
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, Half-Life 2 ist von 2005 irgendwie.
Wie gut das Game eigentlich ausgesehen hat und immer noch aussieht, ne?
Das ist ein Game von 2005.
Ja, so Graphics und so.
Das geht voll klar.
Was bei Half-Life halt auch richtig...
Warflaff 2, das cool war, waren halt die Models und die Gesichtsanimationen und sowas.
Das war ja damals wegweisend mit...
So, geht da jetzt eigentlich meine App noch?
Jetzt habe ich die zwar gebildet.
Okay, Missing Commands, Surf.
Kunst noch, okay.
Und Kekw.
Missing Name, Lul.
Jawohl, okay.
Wichtigsten Commands funktionieren noch, alles gut.
Kekw, XDHD.
gut also wie geht es weiter was kann man noch schönes machen mit mit peiper und
ich muss mal kurz was nachkommen
completion kann das auch
Completion?
Ach.
Ja, das ist ja nice.
Muss man das irgendwie einschalten?
Flip, flip.
Show Completion?
ja cool show completion zsh und jetzt source
und jetzt kann ich sagen ja gut das geht jetzt mit completion natürlich nicht
an der stelle
ok
da müssen wir noch mal hier da rein gehen wo wir das gebildet haben als native native binary
und vermutlich vermutlich müssen wir dann auch einfach nur app nennen
App, show,
minus, minus, show,
completion,
ZSH,
source,
und jetzt,
App,
Aussatz, File, Directory,
Okay.
Completion funktioniert nicht so richtig.
Was ist daran jetzt das Problem?
Env App, no such file or directory.
Kann es sein, dass er nicht klar kommt mit, dass es ein Binary ist?
Für Completion muss die App in deinem Path sein.
Ja.
Ich dachte, das reicht, wenn wir diesen Kempel hier...
Ja, gut.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Path, gleich, Dollar, Path, Doppelpunkt.
Kann ich das einfach so machen?
DVD.
So.
App.
Okay, nice.
Er checkt's.
Es geht!
Guck mal!
Ja, wir haben Autocompletion.
Für die App.
Das ist aber...
Das sagt aber hart, dass das
im Pass sein muss.
Ist das immer so?
Aber finde ich cool,
dass die direkt Completion
eingebaut haben für die Shell.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Gefällt mir.
So, Typer.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier Schönes zu bieten?
Include Completion.
Auto Completion.
Ziemlich cool.
Gefällt mir.
Aha.
So, dann...
dann probieren wir jetzt noch mal was anderes aus und zwar wir machen jetzt noch ein neues command
command und hier das machen wir mal hier ein name weg kommen wir nicht neues command das heißt was
weiß ich ist ja nix sinn verlieren progress oder so progress ports brauchen wir nicht keine option
progress tings und da machen wir jetzt hier rich progress bar wie macht man in rich progress bars
rich progress bar progress bars braucht man öfters angucken wie das funst vor in track
Description Processing
Time Sleep 1
Du nutzt aber wenig AI.
Ich will es ja auch den Kram lernen in dem Fall.
Track
Include Rich Progress
Nee, ich muss einfach nur
Ah, nee, nee, nee, okay
Pass schon
Track, Time, Sleep 1, ja, okay
Time
Time, hallo, please, import
So, und jetzt
Krieg ich jetzt einfach so eine
Progress Bar?
Das wäre nämlich ziemlich easy
Progress
Schick
Das ist einfacher
als mit Spectre-Konsole noch.
Das finde ich in der Tat
sehr, sehr nice.
Massive nice.
Schick.
So, jetzt sind es natürlich die
große Preisfrage.
Wenn ich jetzt
irgendwas ausfüllen will, was länger dauert
und kein Progress anzeigen möchte,
sondern einfach nur Processing.
Also ich will jetzt gar kein Progress anzeigen,
sondern nur, er macht gerade was.
Spinner.
Wie macht man das?
Bridge, Python, Spinner.
Guck mal mal.
Bridge, Spinner.
Spinner.
Dafür musst du vorher wissen, wie viele Steps du machst
Ich glaube nicht, dass du das wissen musst
Ich glaube, man kann hier bestimmt auch so ein Endless-Ding machen
Wo man on the fly updatet
Weil alles andere wäre irgendwie blöd, ja
Also du kannst bestimmt hier irgendwie sagen
Track
Guck mal mal hier, Track
Sequence Description
Also sowas, wo du dann halt
Pro Durchlauf
Den Progress setzt im Endeffekt
Das geht bestimmt
Ich will mir erstmal kurz angucken, wie so ein Spinner funktioniert
Spinner
Okay, das geht nur
Achso
Console Status
Ist das sinnig?
console, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고, 그리고
Okay.
KI lügt.
Console.
Console-AP.
Hä? Wieso?
Ist doch hier.
Oder soll ich das vielleicht...
Oder soll ich das vielleicht besser hier oben
hinschreiben?
Console gleich Console.
So.
Äh, okay.
But why?
Ja, also das ist so was, was mir schon besser gefällt.
Im Endeffekt kannst du jetzt hier sagen, machen wir jetzt hier so was wie Dev Download.
Da machen wir jetzt halt hier Time Sleep oder so rein.
Und dann sagst du hier Download drinnen.
Und das Ding spinnt halt so lange, wie der Download läuft.
Ja, das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
so jetzt jetzt machen wir noch was anderes wie könnte ich jetzt einen
download progress anzeigen mit rich weil ich weiß ja im vorfeld nicht mit dem
track und so
Mach mal Python Minus...
Bridge Spinner.
Ne, da brauche ich UV.
So, ne?
UV.
Run.
Der zeigt dir quasi, was es alles für Spinner gibt.
Nice.
Aber ich mag diesen
Dot-Spinner
Den, den finde ich gut
Hier so, Track
Also jetzt will ich ja mal gucken
Wie könnte ich, wie könnte ich
Sagen wir mal, ich tu mal so, als würde ich
Was downloaden wollen
Und ich will den Track quasi von Hand updaten.
Progress. Basic Usage. Advanced Usage.
Aha.
aha
progress as progress
task at downloading processing cooking
Okay, das will ich. Das will ich eigentlich haben.
Zack.
Progress muss noch imported werden.
Okay, ich nenne das Kommando mal anders.
Ich nenne es Download.
Wir tun so, als ob wir es downloaden würden.
So, dann das da reicht.
Was ist Total in dem Fall?
Total?
Ist ein bisschen blöd, dass man da nicht drüber hofern kann.
das einem anzeigt total number of total steps in progress if defaults 200 ja das ist okay
wir machen jetzt mal keine wir machen jetzt mal keine schleife sondern wir sagen jetzt
einfach mal hier dass der process update task 1 advanced was macht advanced value
und task completed if not none im sleep 1 etwas will einfach mal gucken was passiert
ob das dann 100 ist oder
Download brauche ich.
Ah, nee, okay.
Das ist dann wirklich 1%.
Kann ich nicht einfach es
fest auf den Wert setzen?
Total.
Nee, das ist, wie viel es insgesamt ist.
Das ist nicht der aktuelle Wert, oder?
Ist total der aktuelle Wert?
Weil da muss ich ja
sonst selbst rechnen immer.
Was haben wir hier?
Task
Update
Completed.
10.
Das war's?
Ah!
Da kann man es auf einen festen Wert setzen.
Okay.
Weil dann kann ich jetzt hier sagen, okay,
hiernach sind es jetzt, da muss ich nicht selbst rechnen, ja?
Hiernach sind es 30.
So, und hiernach ist das Ganze fertig.
100.
Einmal, wenn da so ein Download im Hintergrund laufen würde.
ok gut dann lul dankeschön für den sub excel ich muss sagen die api gefällt mir hier das ist das
ist fast noch angenehmer als spektakon soll also meine in dort net ist ja meine meine lieblings
library für so konsolen dinger ist das hier spektakon soll da kannst du auch so dinger
mitmachen. Da kannst du zum Beispiel auch hier
sagen, Progress.
Progress Bar.
Die haben
ihre Webseite geändert.
Progress Bars. Guck,
das sieht sehr ähnlich aus. Findet ihr nicht
auch? Die Frage ist,
hat sich Rich das davon abgeguckt
oder haben die sich das von Rich abgeguckt?
Wahrscheinlich haben die sich das eher von Rich abgeguckt.
Guck,
Process, Progress, Start,
Das sieht schon sehr ähnlich aus.
Hast du dir Typer schon mal angeschaut?
Das ist Typer.
Geht Completed 101?
Wir checken mal, ob das geht.
Ne.
Ne, geht nicht.
Geht nicht.
Dann setzt es auf maximal 100.
Also die Uhrzeit daneben finde ich schon mal richtig dumm.
Das würde ich da erst gar nicht...
Wie kann man denn das customizen?
Dass man sagt, ich will gar keine Uhrzeit und so Zeug anzeigen.
Columns.
Ah ja, das ist auch nicht schlecht
Ja, okay, okay, man kann auch quasi sowas anzeigen
Bevor es richtig losgeht
Columns
Genau, und hier kann man angeben
was man da alles haben will.
Also, Progress?
Wie macht man das jetzt klar?
Progress?
Äh.
Oh, Alter, das ist hässlich.
Hässlich AF.
By the way, Chat,
warum muss ich überhaupt sagen,
with Progress?
Warum kann ich denn nicht einfach sowas hier machen?
Und das einfach weglassen.
Das müsste doch eigentlich auch funktionieren.
Okay, Text, mach mal Text Column.
Aber mach mal die Default-Sachen rein.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen gefällt ihm das nicht.
Ja.
das macht gar nichts okay das juckt nicht
und ja start vorher vielleicht sagen okay da kann man sich das ja komplett sparen
Aber wie würde ich es denn richtig machen?
With progress.
So, und dann würde ich sagen, Textcolumn,
Barcolumn,
Time remaining.
Also ich will nur, okay, wenn ich nur diese 3 will.
Also er hat auf jeden Fall schon mal irgendwelche Type-Hint-Probleme,
weiß nicht genau, was dafür. Aber
okay, das funktioniert jetzt, verstehe ich.
Aber das ist schon richtig eklige
Syntax, ne?
Da fragen wir mal, fragen wir doch
mal gerade hier.
Wir fragen mal die Chinesen KI.
Make it more
beautiful.
Warte bis zu TQDM.
Was? TQDM?
Was ist das?
Das ist eine extra Library für Progress.
Oh, mein Auge.
Ich sehe nichts.
Close.
Da sieht die
Rich Progress Bar aber deutlich
schöner aus als das.
Warum sollte ich das verwenden versus die Rich Progress Bar?
JLM Python, was ist denn das schon wieder?
Generalized Linear Models, okay.
Das Wort meint ihr jetzt aber nicht, oder?
Oder meinst du ChatGPT?
Das nutzen super viele Leute
Aber wenn man Rich eh schon verwendet
Warum nicht Rich benutzen
Okay
More beautiful ist das in der Tat nicht
Das ist doch hässlich wie die Nacht
Alter
Ist das wirklich the way
Es zu schreiben, so wie ich das hier gemacht hab
With progress
Was macht denn with überhaupt
Is used to wrap the execution of a block
With methods defined by a column
Schreibe was
Das ist wie using
Das heißt der destructort dann
Den progress bar danach
Und was stört den jetzt hier da dran?
Expected Text Column.
Matched Generic Type.
What?
Okay.
Die Type Annotations sind für mich noch etwas unverständlich, was der jetzt will.
Soll ich das weglassen hier oder was will er mir sagen?
Nee.
Oder doch?
Hä?
Chat.
Das funzt jetzt trotzdem?
Ich bin richtig hart verwirrt gerade.
Darf ich das einfach weglassen, oder was?
Nee.
Ja, using block.gc sharp war eklig.
Ich finde hier diese Geschichte mit using var blub gleich 0w finde ich auch viel praktischer.
So ganz checke ich noch nicht, was der hier für Schmerzen hat.
Expected type string oder progress column.
Got Console Renderable Rich Casts instead.
Ah ja.
Also.
So, ich muss Progress, Progress column oder was?
Aber sowas gibt es doch gar nicht.
Oder so?
Ne.
Ey, keine Ahnung. Das ist mir jetzt zu hoch.
Warte mal. Warum?
Gerade schon dabei sind.
Warum meckert hier die EDE wegen Type Hints?
Ist grundsätzlich gültiger, warum die EDE meckert.
Progress erwartet verschiedene Progress Column Objekte.
Die Klassen sind alle passenden Spalten.
Chat-GPT labert, oder?
Hä?
Das ist doch dumm, das ist doch dumm, Fug, was das da erzählt.
Okay, das ist das Stumpfbuch
Keine Ahnung, ist die
Ah, ja, damit ist die Ursache ziemlich eindeutig
Ach ja
Das hier ist genau die normale Verwendung von Rich.
Ja, aber...
Alter, Chat-GPT.
Das mache ich doch gerade schon.
Das ist...
Oh, das ist wieder so Lower-IQ-Scheiß, Alter.
Ja, ich soll Rich aktualisieren.
Natürlich.
Klar, Chat.
Das ist es ganz bestimmt.
Okay, ich ignoriere jetzt einfach
Mal gucken, was mir die Idee vorschlägt
Put comma separated elements on one line
Das wird es aber nicht fixen
Gut
Was auch immer
Ich bin zu dumm dafür zu checken, was mir die Type Hints
Sagen wollen
Pyjama ist da nicht
Pfeifert genug, meinst du?
Ah, das kann sein
Aber die, ich muss sagen
Guck mal hier, Blue
Die haben sich das super abgeguckt
mal hier, passt mal auf. Spectre
Console
Guck mal.
Leute, die haben sich das
voll abgeguckt.
Guck mal.
Green
Markup.
Ist es jetzt die
Frage, hat sich Spectre Console von
Rich abgeguckt oder Rich von Spectre Console?
Aber ich glaube, Spectre Console hat sich von Rich abgeguckt.
Weil das ist genau
der gleiche Kram.
Jetzt muss man eigentlich hier danach noch
closen, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
Oh, viel interessanter natürlich noch.
Weil ich die Farben
super hässlich finde.
Wie ändert man die Farben?
Ändert man die hier mit der Bar?
Bar Column?
Weil hübsch ist das nicht.
Spinner Column
Progress Get
Also das muss ich mir irgendwann nochmal angucken
Wie man hier die, weil die Farben finde ich nicht hübsch
Dieses komische
Magenta und dann das Grüne und so
Da ist
weniger Farbe manchmal mehr.
Und das Downloading
muss auch beim besten Willen nicht blue sein.
Was ist das eigentlich?
Spinner Column.
Progress Get
Default Column.
Moment.
Da muss man ein Sternchen?
Was zum?
Chat.
Was bedeutet ein Sternchen?
Das wird nicht Pointer Dereference sein, oder?
Ah, Unpacking.
Also quasi sowas hier.
Also dass der quasi den Kram hier drin einsetzt.
Okay, okay.
Ich understande.
Spinner Column.
Also Text Column, Progress, Description.
Das ist okay.
Dann Bar kommt weg.
Kommt eine Spinner Column rein.
Die geht nicht, weil die nicht importiert ist.
Task Process.
Okay, nochmal gucken.
Ah, das finde ich viel, viel schicker schon einmal.
Und die Spinner Column, die soll gefälligst vorne hin.
Das ist doch schick.
Ganz ehrlich, das gefällt mir viel besser.
Das gefällt mir doch viel besser, wie das da spinnert vorne.
So, und jetzt kann man der Spinner-Column auch sagen, welchen Spinner man verwenden will.
Spinner?
Wie kann man hier die Dinger suggesten?
Style?
Keine Ahnung.
Guck mal hier.
Spinner?
Ich habe noch eine Idee, was wir machen können.
Und kann man jetzt hier die Sachen autocomplieten irgendwie?
Nee, oder?
Aber das können wir uns hier mit Minus Dust, hier konnten wir uns das doch angucken.
Also, mit Less geht das natürlich nicht.
Also, hier nehmen wir mal...
Nehmen wir mal Dots.
Okay, Dots.
Dots ist aber, glaube ich, auch Default.
dann können wir hier noch sagen
Spinner
Finish Text
Moment
Rich Emojis
Wie setzt man Emojis ein?
Das geht bestimmt auch
Herr F-Programmer
Äh Quatsch
Rich
Wie setzt man Emojis ein?
Rich Emoji
Kann ich da jetzt sagen hier
Bridge
Emoji
Optional
Konsole
Emoji
Aber warum sollte ich überhaupt
Bridge für Emojis verwenden
Und nicht einfach hier
Ein Häkchen
Reinkopie pasten
Ist doch wahrscheinlich viel sinniger
Oh zack
Weil jetzt sollte der
Jetzt sollte der ja
Downloaden und wenn er fertig downloaden ist
Ein Häkchen anzeigen
Das ist doch schick
Das ist doch schick, das hat doch was
So, das einzige, was mich jetzt noch daran stört ist
Dass die Farben gefallen mir nicht
Das muss ich mir gerade nochmal angucken
Wie man die Farben von dem Download Progress angeben kann
Text Process Column
Style
Text Format
Style of Output
Markup
Show Speed
Ja das so genau
Textformat
Format for Percentage Display
Defaults to Progress
Percentage
Task
Okay und da könnte ich jetzt quasi reinschreiben
Aber
Ist denn dann
Aber da ist ja immer noch
eine Farbe drumherum.
Kann ich die jetzt so überschreiben?
Oder muss ich jetzt hier sagen Blue?
Ne.
Tja, da bin ich jetzt
etwas ratlos.
Wir fragen nochmal den Chat.
Die hat uns ja heute
noch nicht eine sinnvolle Antwort geliefert.
äh
hallo
change text color
of progress column
style
ach
ach so
green, das funzt jetzt oder was
ha
Also Chat-GPT kannst du ja heute mal komplett in die Tonne kloppen.
Aber komplett, Alter.
Das hat überhaupt keinen Plan.
Schlechtes KI ever.
Wir fragen jetzt mal die China-KI.
Mal gucken, ob die China-KI besser ist.
Die China-Chinesen-KI.
Leider sind die nicht mehr usable.
Okay.
Change
Text Color
Python Bridge.
Vielleicht. Aha.
To change task colors
use
like red green
der task description vieles ob das ja es ist okay das ist bin ich nicht so
wirklich nicht zu dumm für die modus der google google wird wissen
Moment, man kann eine Text-Column
anstatt
eine Percentage-Column
machen.
Äh.
Ach, das ist im Prinzip das gleiche, oder was?
Und da kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, Blue...
Alter!
Warum ist das so kompliziert?
Ich schreibe jetzt einfach nur Kek W rein.
Okay, das ist prinzipiell Funst.
Kann ich?
Okay, okay.
Ich kann doch einfach
das hier weglassen, oder?
Easy.
Easy. Okay.
Ja, und ganz ehrlich,
so finde ich das nämlich deutlich, deutlich
angenehmer.
Und jetzt zur Frage vom AF-Programmer.
Kann man
den Text ändern
bei 100%?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Also ich würde mal vermuten,
dann muss man wahrscheinlich sowas hier machen.
Keine Ahnung, ob das so sinnig ist,
was ich da jetzt fabriziere.
Okay, das ist FUNZ.
Und dann kann man hier wahrscheinlich sagen,
Calum.
Und dann sowas wie Style oder so.
Oder irgendwie kann man das dann nachträglich...
Format?
Nee, man kann da nichts setzen nachträglich, oder?
man kann das okay man kann das nachträglich nicht change wenn es einmal gesetzt ist oder
Oder sehe ich doch richtig?
Das heißt ja auch nur String.
Tja.
Das geht anscheinend nicht.
Mal gucken, ob die China-Chinesen-KI schlauer ist.
Oh, Alter.
Alter.
Mein Auge.
Okay.
Die Seite der China-Chinesen-KI macht mich fertig.
dynamic color changes based on progress wie da muss man eine klasse für anlegen
okay das ist das ist sechs hat das machen wir jetzt nicht kannst du
auch überschreiben mit was denn?
Ich würde sagen,
progress, task, progress, column.
Da kommt ja nur ein String zurück.
Kann man vielleicht
progress die column dann
überschreiben, dass man
sagt,
Columns
und die dann neu setzen.
Ist das hier ein Array?
Oder was ist das jetzt?
Also so wirklich schön ist das glaube ich nicht,
wie man das hier macht.
Dass ich jetzt hier sagen, Columns,
ist das ein Array? Eins.
Also
0, 1, 2.
So.
Macht das Sinn?
Nein.
Topel Object does not support Item Assignment.
Gut.
Index.
Return.
Nee, das ist Read Only.
Kann man nicht setzen.
Okay, da bin ich jetzt überfragt, wie das funktioniert.
Wir lassen es erstmal unformatiert.
Aber ich muss sagen, trotzdem, die API von Rich gefällt mir gut.
Vor allem, was ich richtig cool finde, dass man danach noch was anzeigen lassen kann.
Richtig nice.
So, nächste Sache ist, Rich, wie macht man Tabellen?
Tabellen ist auch immer so ein Ding, wo viele Libraries failen.
erinnert ihr euch noch dran wie ich mich aufgeregt habe dass es keine gescheite
formatting library für tables und progress bars in rust gibt gibt nichts
gescheites in rust sagt alles oder in go in go auch nicht
und man toastbrot essen schon ganz kalt
ok
Haben die nicht erweiterte Array-Typen
wie Maps und Dictionaries drin?
Wie meinst du das?
Also Go hat mich richtig abgefuckt.
Mit Tabellen und Progress Bars.
Go hatte diese ganze Bubble Tea,
Bubble Rap oder wie der ganze Shit heißt.
Alles Schrott.
Okay, so macht man Tabellen.
So macht man Tabellen in Rich.
Äh, Rich Table.
Mal eine ganz bescheuerte Frage.
Ja.
Warum machen die hier immer Console gleich Console?
Warum kann man nicht einfach so machen?
Das ist doch viel besser.
Oh.
Cannot import name console from rich.
Warum nicht?
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen.
Rich.console.
Bäm.
Warum? Warum kannst du hier nichts?
Warum kannst du das nicht importen?
Was ist das Problem?
What?
Okay, da bin ich zu Python-Loop für.
Wo ist das Problem?
From rich import console.
From rich?
From rich console import console.
Und jetzt Konsol, ne?
So.
Okay, nice.
Okay, Tabellen-Mode gefällt mir schon mal gut.
Title.
Cute Chatters.
Name.
Lass mal alles weg.
Kein Rap.
Name.
Sub.
Keine Ahnung.
kekw
so
table add row
das kann man da jetzt machen
name
der f-programmer ist da drin am Start
der ist
kein sub
Anzeige ist raus
und der ist
furchtbar kekw
was auch immer das bedeuten soll
Okay.
Eis.
Das gefällt mir echt ganz gut,
wie man Tables machen kann.
Fight Strike.
Mal ein paar Leute hier rein.
Der ist
nix davon und der Serious Max,
der kommt auch noch rein.
Da haben wir alles.
Aber der ist, der ist sub hier.
Okay, gut.
Nächste
wichtige Frage.
Wie macht man
rounded corners?
vorne
Table Option
Heading
Header Style
Border Styles
Ah, Ridge
is nice
Warum hat das noch keiner portet für Rust?
Die sollen mal die ganzen Scheiß zu rewriten
Da sollen die mal Rich nach Rust portieren
Oder nach Go
Ich weiß hier, es gibt paar Projekte
Rich AS und so
Das sind aber KI-Slop-Projekte
Nur die Leute nur machen
Für ihre Resüme
Resüme
Oh, vor 18 Stunden hat er was gemacht
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, dass das überhaupt noch supported ist.
Das letzte ist am Februar.
So, wie ging das hier? Border.
Border?
Border-Style?
Okay, aber ganz ehrlich, die IDE-Experience in Python ist immer noch nicht so geil.
Moment
Box
Ich hab nix gesagt, das ist nicht Borderstyle
Das ist Box
Aber hier, hier kann ich jetzt nix
Nix Auto
Completen an der Stelle, die mir das anzeigen würde
So, ich muss jetzt sagen, Box
Punkt
Box ist nicht importiert
Import rich box
Und das kann ich sagen, okay
Double Edge, Heavy, Horizontal, Minimal, Simple, Rounded.
Beste.
Excellent.
Sehr schöne Tabelle.
Sehr, sehr schick.
Du kannst dir den Twitch-Chat...
Sehr gute Idee, Max.
Excellent.
Twitch-Chatters anzeigen lassen.
Genau.
Dann bei der Gelegenheit können wir uns auch gleich mal angucken,
wie macht man denn...
Moment, das muss ich mir gerade noch mal hier irgendwo...
Wie macht man denn...
Wie macht man denn ordentlich HTTP-Requests?
Da gibt es bestimmt was halbwegs Sinniges in...
Warte mal.
http.client.
Äh.
Eher nicht, oder?
Eher nicht.
Python
stand-and-lib
get-request
json
Vor 15 Jahren!
Lull.
Okay, Import Requests.
Headers, Get Requests.
Alles klar, also.
Ach, ich dachte schon, dass es da was gibt.
Re-
Requests?
Ah, fast.
Fast AP Requests.
Okay.
Requests.
Wie funzt das jetzt was?
Get.
import request aber das immer so
ach das ist ein eigenes package
peyton stelle clip get request chasen
da schön ist was anderes schön ist was anderes
Import will open.
JSON import
from
Ich drücke einfach nur Enter. Data.
Funds das denn überhaupt jetzt?
Geil!
Forbidden!
Max, warum ist das
verbinden sollte eigentlich nicht oder
Sekunde.
Geht doch alles.
Ah, kann es sein, weil es keine Header gesetzt hat?
Das ist, weil er keine Header gesetzt hat.
Wett ich mit dir.
das war keine händler gesetzt hat
Das geht jetzt
Äh, Request
Pass auf, BAM geht
Fuck, warum?
Was hat der für Probleme?
dann legt es nicht das am
liegt es am agent
marxist debate es geht nicht
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, weil der User Agent nicht stimmt.
Wie heißt der richtige User Agent hier?
User Agent?
Ach, du meinst das?
Ja, aber das sollte doch keinen Unterschied machen, oder?
Das ist doch eigentlich egal.
User Agent.
Wie war das?
Mozilla, Firefox.
Bam.
Beste.
So.
Ah, nee, war nicht User Agent.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt geht.
Max, da Invalid Header Name User Agent.
Achso, wegen des Doppelpunktes.
Bäm, Max, das war's.
Ich hab deinen Server outplayed.
eine ahnung was er für schmerzen hat
da machen wir jetzt mal eine eigene funktion draus die ich jetzt eigentlich download get data
besser besser haben da weißt du weißt du ob schein der so schön nicht sagen
return dort kriege ich hier jason gedöns zurück
Should be lowercase.
Okay.
Äh.
Jason Content, so.
Get data. Wunderbar.
Oh. Jason Content.
Und
den, wie lupe ich den jetzt
gescheit?
Und
Wie macht man Jason in...
Kann ich jetzt hier noch sagen, was der returnt?
Der returnt Jason.
Ja.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Was macht dann Jason?
load
Kann ich jetzt da irgendwie drauf zugreifen
Und er bringt und brennt kann ich einmal und ihr lasst uns schon mal
Und da wie sieht wie sieht dieser request aus
es gibt quasi einen array mit items chat message date username ok also will ich jetzt im endeffekt
darauf zugreifen, auf
falls
das so geht, ne, Items.
Okay, das funzt so. Das ist schon mal nice.
Und jetzt würde ich gerne
loopen da drüber.
Vor.
Oder kann man sowas hier machen?
Sowas wie Loop oder so.
Why?
Ne.
Vor
I in
Aha
Print F I
Funds noch alles?
Ja
For item in items
So und da kann ich jetzt
sagen. Print. Was hatten wir hier nochmal?
JQ. Was ist da nochmal drin?
Username. User ID.
Okay, machen wir User Name.
Printen wir mal nur den, äh, warte mal. Item.
Item. Punkt.
Username, ne?
Ne.
Quatsch.
So.
Username.
Kunst. Nice.
Was haben wir sonst noch drin?
JQ, was gibt es hier für Dinge?
Sieht man, ob die Leute
subscribed sind?
Subscriber.
Und Turbo machen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Geht ja zum Testen hier.
Turbo.
Das kommt weg.
Also, jetzt wird hier geloopt
gleich.
Geloopt. Genau.
Add Row.
Add row.
Item.
Username.
So.
Als nächstes.
Hex.
For user.
Kann man ein bisschen besser lesen.
Username.
So.
Hex.
Hast du übrigens eine schöne API designt hier.
Subscriber
Und als letztes
Ist es Subscriber?
Ja
Und als letztes wollen wir haben
Mod
Machen wir mal so, Mod
Mal gucken, ob noch alles läuft
Bam!
Sehr nice.
Exquisite.
Guck mal, hier haben wir die Chatters.
Mach unten noch ein Total.
Ja, das ist mir zu high IQ jetzt.
Warte mal kurz, was ist?
So.
Ah, das gefällt mir. Das hat was.
Wo bist du? Du bist jetzt dabei.
Guck. Bam.
Also sobald die
API aktualisiert hat, bist du dabei.
Was macht das hier? Die letzten...
Die letzten 50 Chat-Nachrichten oder was
macht das hier?
Das heißt, die...
Der Vatras hat gechattet.
Das habe ich gerade mitgekriegt.
Wo hat er was? Wo hat er was geschrieben?
Gar nichts geschrieben.
Er hat gebatet.
Ach, nach Date sortieren muss ich das
Das muss ich aber bei deinem API-Request machen, oder?
Und sort gleich
Irgendwie
Ja
Und sort gleich
Minus Date
Nope
Oder einfach nur Date?
Nope.
Achso, Date.
Oh, jetzt machen wir deine Datenbank aber ziemlich hart belastet gerade.
Guck mal, jetzt seid ihr auch hier am Start.
Oh, jetzt hämmern wir aber deine Datenbank ziemlich gerade.
Die ist hart mit Sorten beschäftigt.
Komm, wir machen mal ein bisschen weniger.
Wir machen mal nur die letzten 10.
Ja, okay, das geht ein bisschen schneller.
Das sind Doppelte.
Ah ja, die Leute chatten halt auch so viel hier.
Natürlich sind die doppelt.
Das ist ja pro Chatnachricht.
50 letzten Chatnachrichten.
So, und jetzt können wir noch eine Sache machen.
Also als letzte Amtshandlung.
Wenn einer Subscriber ist, kann man in Python sowas machen?
Wenn der Subscriber ist, dann geht sowas?
Oder?
Nee, oder?
Gibt's nicht.
Guck mal.
Python Ternary Operator.
Gibt's da sowas?
If H
Else
Moment, was?
Das check ich nicht
Das ist mir zu
If
Ne, hä?
What?
Okay, was?
Also if
Okay, machen wir das mal hier
Status
If user tag subscriber
If
Aber age
Ich will einfach gucken, ob der Inhalt
Ach so
Quasi Häkchen
ja Häkchen
und dann hier gucken
if user
ist quasi gleich gleich 1
else
achso ok
ähm
so hier
na
äh
Das ist die Idee.
Ist zu dumm dafür.
So, und jetzt machen wir hier Status.
Das sollte jetzt funzen.
Oh, hier sind alle keine Subscribers.
Was ist denn da los?
Aber es muss ja auch kein Subscriber sein.
Ihr könnt jetzt Follower werden.
Es steht dann drinnen auch
ob Follower... Nee, gell?
Follower steht nicht drin.
Chat, aber ernst gemeint, wenn euch der Stream-Content
gefällt, ich würde mich sehr
über einen, so richtig über einen Follower freuen,
weil es mich immer wahnsinnig motiviert,
wenn es grüne Pfeile nach oben
gibt. Natürlich nur, wenn es euch gefällt.
Wenn ihr sagt so ein Kack,
Max, verpiss dich,
dann nicht.
Nee, ob Follower
oder nicht, sieht man nicht.
Excellent.
So, im Prinzip können wir das jetzt
auch noch hier machen.
Mod, quasi
if
user mod
dann so, ansonsten so.
Ja, ist doch jetzt eigentlich ganz gut lesbar, oder?
App
Keine Mods
Keine Sorge, jetzt müsste
Jetzt müsste
Der Max drin stehen
Du bist aber kein Mod
Warum nicht?
Hm
Muss ich da so machen?
Weil Text oder was?
Ah.
Es ist nicht JavaScript auf jeden Fall.
Merkt man da schon mal.
Okay, cool.
Ja, nice.
Also, da muss ich ehrlich gesagt sagen,
Rich, also die API und Konsolen-App,
das hat schon was.
Das sieht schon wirklich sehr leserlich und hübsch aus.
Gut, das hier ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so geil.
Aber das sieht schon ganz gut aus.
Also ich muss sagen, das gefällt mir von der Optik und der Usability besser, als so Commandline-Zeug in Go zu machen.
Go ist aber halt trotzdem der absolute King für Commandline-Anwendungen, weil Self-Contained Binaries easy zu erstellen.
Jetzt machen wir hier als letztes noch einen Compile-Vorgang.
Bild und guck mal, wie schnell er jetzt
Compiled
Michael
50 Milliarden, moin
Lange nicht mehr gesehen, danke schön für den Sub
Aus Frankfurt
Warst du
Im Bahnhofsviertel unterwegs, ein bisschen
Weil
Da hätte ich, wie gesagt
Kann ich dir nur
Dieses Ding hier empfehlen, Korean Fried Chicken
an der elbe straße beste beste richtig geiles essen und preislich auch vollkommen okay
viewer treff keck rate ab bin ich da bin ich der falsche für fallen wie sieht so ein treffen aus
irgendwelche it keller kinder treffen andere it keller kinder das funktioniert nicht weil endlich
Video. Ich war mit dem Fabian
zusammen vor zwei Wochen oder
drei Wochen kurz davor, was aufzunehmen.
Aber dann war der Fabian so krass
motiviert, dass er selbst auf seinem
Channel was aufgenommen hat und dann
haben wir irgendwie nicht mal geschrieben danach, obwohl das
eigentlich immer noch steht.
Obwohl das immer noch steht, ja.
Obwohl wir das immer noch machen wollen.
So, was macht unsere compiled
Anwendung? Ist die jetzt fertig mal compiled?
Also, das ging auf jeden Fall
deutlich schneller.
Das geht mit dem Cache auf jeden Fall deutlich schneller.
Schauen wir mal, ob kompiliert auch noch alles funktioniert.
Ja.
Äh
Chat, der hat Probleme mit SSL
Was wird das Videothema?
Das wissen wir noch nicht
Der hat Probleme mit dem
Warum
Das ist jetzt irgendein
Das ist jetzt irgendein SSL Ding
Also
So sehr mir das gefällt
Die Sprache an sich
Solange man keine gescheiten
Single
Self-Contained Binary Sachen machen kann
Ohne Probleme
benutzt er nicht die System-CAs?
Benutzt er nicht die System-CAs?
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht.
Keine Ahnung.
Weil wenn ich das
hier
Wenn ich das hier curle,
hat mein Curl damit
überhaupt keine Probleme.
Ja, keine Ahnung, was das Binary macht.
Das sagt in der Tat ein bisschen.
Also ich mag die Sprache.
Mir gefallen die Frameworks, die ich bisher gesehen habe.
Aber gerade CLI-Tools musst du ordentlich als Single Binary bündeln können.
Da kann die Sprache noch so schön sein und die Frameworks noch so nice.
Wenn das nicht geht, du kannst halt deine CLI-Tools nicht gescheit verteilen.
PIP System Search brauchst du.
Was ist denn das?
PIP System Search?
What?
Ur-Lip doesn't handle this.
Certify.
Das Issue habe ich ja gerade.
Certify where?
What?
Okay, man kann das also umgehen.
Ist nicht.
Also, was muss ich machen?
Urlib Request
will open
CA-File
Context. Boah, das ist ja
richtig eklig.
Ja, man kann natürlich das auch ausschalten.
Du kannst Verify ausschalten.
Jaja, das
geht schon, aber das
ist vielleicht nicht so das Allersinnigste.
Wo macht er hier?
Wo macht er hier URL open?
Da, Request URL open.
So, haben wir Request.
Äh.
Was muss da jetzt noch rein?
Kontext.
Kontext gleich.
SSL default.
Das ist halt auch wieder richtig krass hässlich.
Kontext.
SSL, create
import SSL
certify
install and import
package certify, ok, meinetwegen
ok, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob es hier
im Container noch funzt
ok, funzt noch
build, sollte jetzt ja auch schnell gehen
Gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt gefixt ist.
Das muss man auf jeden Fall in der eigenen Funktion
rappen, weil sonst drehst du ja am Rad,
wenn du das jedes Mal schreiben musst.
Ich glaube das bringt mir nichts, weil ich bundle das ja.
Wenn ich das einfach nur installiert habe, ist es ja in meinem Binary nicht drinne.
So das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an und dann gehe ich aufs Klo und gehe auf.
Ist ja so mal kurz mein Toastbrot fertig.
Ah, guck mal hier.
Der hat sogar gecheckt, dass er das
includen muss. Das Certified
Ding.
Äh, 4.2
ist noch nicht raus.
4.2 ist noch nicht raus
Guck
Noch nicht released
Bam
Es funzt, Leute
Mal gucken, wie groß
22 MB
Spinery wird immer größer, aber ich meine,
so platten Platz ist ja heute kein Problem.
Aber es funzt alles.
Nice.
Da muss man sich dran gewöhnen.
Sehr schön.
Chat, schön, dass so viele von euch dabei gewesen sind
heute.
Exzellent.
Warum die meisten Sprachen...
Python funktioniert ja auch.
Das liegt jetzt an meinem Bundle, was ich da gemacht habe.
schön, dass du mal wieder da warst.
Leute, es hat mir sehr gefallen.
Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Wir sehen uns dann im nächsten Stream.
Und wie gesagt, wenn es euch gefallen hat,
ich freue mich sehr über
einen Follow. Follow Beste.
Grüne Pfeile nach oben.
Bis dann. Wir sehen uns
im nächsten Stream. Macht's gut.
See you.